-Hey, guys, WrestleMania 35
is this weekend,
and my favorite part
is all the smack talk.
[ Laughter ]
You gotta make
your opponent scared
before they even step
into the ring with you.
So, it got me thinking,
could wrestlers make any
trash talk seem intimidating?
To find out, we asked kids
to send us their best taunts
and see if WWE superstars could
still make them terrifying.
It's time for "Kid Trash Talk."
Here we go.
♪♪
-♪ Kids talk trash ♪
♪ Trash talk ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now, remember, these were all
written by real kids.
Here to do our first taunt
is the winner of last year's
WWE Greatest Royal Rumble.
Give it up for Braun Strowman!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-You want a piece of me?!
Do you want a piece of me?!
I'm gonna kick your butt
till you fall in a lake.
And I'm not joking!
Because when I'm kidding,
I say, "Knock, knock!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Applause continues ]
-[ Laughing ]
All right.
Next, give it up for the former
WWE SmackDown Women's Champion,
Carmella!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Come at me, you noodle.
I'll wax you New York style.
♪♪
-Mm, wow.
Next up is the two-time
WWE Tag Team Champion,
Drew McIntyre!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-I am gonna shove my foot
so far up your butt...
that you are gonna be
pooping toes for a week!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Next, give it up for three-time
WWE Raw Women's Champion
Alexa Bliss!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-I'm hungry.
So guess what I'm gonna do?
I'm gonna take your lunch box
and eat your lunch.
-Whoa.
-Gosh.
♪♪
Next up is one of
the longest-reigning tag team
champions in WWE history,
Kofi Kingston!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Yeah. Hold up, hold up,
hold up, hold up.
Hey, check it out.
You look like a potato and
a chicken nugget had a baby!
Oh!
Got 'em!
♪♪
-And, finally, we have
a two-time WWE World Champion.
Give it up for Seth Rollins!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Don't make me bake a pie
and put your face in it,
'cause your butt is your face,
and your face is your butt!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Give it up
for the WWE superstars!
WrestleMania 35 will take place
at MetLife Stadium
this Sunday, April 7th,
at 7:00 P.M. Eastern,
and will stream live
on WWE Network.
Stick around. We'll be
right back with Alec Baldwin.
♪♪